horizon zero dawn cements world is
filled with a bunch of creatures that
while beautiful in their own special way
will usually stop at nothing to kill you
fortunately our main girl a Lloyd has
the ability to override the beasts and
in some cases even mount them if you're
in the mood for hunting though you can
check out our gameplay video of the
craziest creatures in the game but if
all you want to do is tame these
magnificent beasts then climb aboard and
I'll show you how it's done first in
order to override a machine you'll need
to find a complete The Associated
dungeons known as cauldrons in the game
each cauldron has a huge network of
robotic caves and beating them will give
you the ability to override a specific
group of machines for example beating
cauldron Sigma grants access to the
sawtooth scrapper Grazer and Lance horn
once you snuck up on the machine and
convinced them to be on your team it
will happily fight alongside you
overridden machines will only be on your
side for a limited time but it's enough
to help you take down some of the
stronger enemies in the game fire up and
override on one of the behemoths and let
er rip surely nothing bad will come from
this
oh boy but if you're just sick and tired
of running around everywhere and when a
dedicated mount to halt your lazy butt
from place to place called rim psi is
the one you want and luckily the game is
pretty generous in providing you with
this because after completing one of the
main story missions early on in the game
a boy is given the override ability for
the first group of machines no dungeon
required there are three machines you'll
be able to tame and actually mount the
Strider the broadhead and the charger
just sneak up behind one of them hold
triangle to channel the override and
congratulations you are now the proud
owner of a mechanical deer good mileage
nice handling while a LOI will be able
to travel faster with the mount
she actually won't be able to pick up
any supplies while riding it and you can
forget about being stealthy as no
self-respecting machine is going to let
a human riding one of their own kind
sneak up on them but it still feels
pretty satisfying to wrangle the beasts
and claim them as your own
and that's all there is to it there are
plenty of other machines in the game for
you to discover so I want to hear what
your favorites are let me know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
lots more horizon zero dawn videos
you